Okay, so the printer is finished is spitting out all six
pieces for the back here
one here, two, three, four, five, six
I modeled in little sockets for magnets here
the most satisfying thing in the world to hear
I think they're here. I think they're here
Down There They've Like a State-Of-The-Art Electric Skateboard
Australian Company They Started off as a Diy Build your Own
Electric Skateboard Company They Sold The Motors the Speed Controller Boards the Battery and You Would put This all Together then They Had Their first
Part The Raptor One
but then Thanks to the last year or two Just like
Developing This Monster of A skateboard like Literally Nothing Else on the Market
comes Close to this. Too fast. Invited Them over Just Because I wanted to ride it
to try This Thing The 2020 I feel, is like A
Baseline 20 Miles an Hour 20 Miles of range that's what I would like, oh my god today, oh?
Yeah
all my Hair is Sticking out
I'm red Hood
How much Sticking out There you go go yeah
But it fits. my head fits in it it actually Worked actually spent the last Night Working in This D he busted up his
Epoxy Sculpt he Just Kind of Takes a little Printing error in The Nose here so now We Have the Helmet Another segment
Attached it all Together First Thing Is tape to hold Everything in Place After Ended The Friction Welding I use a drywall Compound
To kind of go
Over the Ridges Here and Smooth Them out a little bit and I will sand the heck out of it and then Paint it well
Prime it and Then Paint it who knows what I'll do with it when it's all Done Maybe I'll Take some Cosplay Photos Or I
Don't know I mean no one Really Cares About red Hood
the Joker
Was a first red Hood but that's all out war ruined by Alan Moore it was his Origin for the Joker but
He doesn't count it as A real Ordinance Joker has no real order I think so yeah
Yeah it's Robin Jason Todd he Supposedly died bring him back With the Lazarus pit
Goes Crazy Becomes Rid of it
And he Kills People that's why, you things like that also Better
So here's what happened, We were out in Chinatown, we were Walking down the street and nick Walked
By A couple of Swords from a Popular Video Game and Kind
Of like A ghost Gotcha He's Trying to get Me and then you Didn't want to do Any Push-ups on the Street
Peanuts Streets in La Street, yeah it's Dirty, but you can do Push-ups With your knuckles so then he Gets in the car
and then
We get out?
of the car
Here and he doesn't want to do them on the street here Either so there Needs to come Inside and for every Time you move
A double gate to do 40
Red Bull it gives You Wheels is this what this is are, We are Responsive our Red Bull Analysis Is that what this means?
We don't know we're Doing battlegrounds Video and I heard rumblings that
We're Going to be Sponsored by red Bull for that this Guy Knocks and it's like hey someone order Some Red Bull, we're like
No he's like, well too Bad here's Some red Bull
So can, We like Actually start drinking These right Now Or, do We have to wait
I'm done yet, sorry here's the Drywall Compound to fill in the Seams and then did the XTC 3D Resident
Over That Palm Sanding it all Down the Drywall
Didn't hold up the seams start the Show Through Managed using Wood Putty so it's Basically this like
Gooey Kind of Play-doh
It's actually Purple until it dries Into drive so i put on the Helmet Actually got my fingers A
Little Wet to kind of Smooth it Down and then just did a relatively Expanding Path and
Then A light Primer Pass Because you can
Really See your Imperfection on the Service Once You use primer and it's Actually looking Pretty good fill in the Gaps Pretty
Well like There's A bit of A?
Gap here Which Is pretty Smooth now this is all pretty Smooth so there's Still some slight bumps in Here From like I haven't Sanded
Everything Down Fully Like This Part Needs a higher grit Pass Right There We Spend a little more Time Actually Standing it
Getting it Smooth Problems Are Going to Gotten Monday Tuesday Wednesday next Week Shooting I leave on Thursday to go to the Boundary Waters
So it's gonna be like Two Weeks before I finish you know I want
Oh I'm going to I'm gonna Paint it right Now and so
I don't know what its Gonna be Finished but if You subscribe you will Make Sure never to miss it
at some Point Randomly Surprisingly finished Helm able to Pop Up in the Video
We Recently got This Board and to be Completely Honest it's?
Fantastic Mmm it's dead Silent I don't know if You have the Remote for it Anywhere They
Advertise like ten Miles Around tom Powers like the
V2 Boost Support Because I use this Transport Like I need High Quality Metal I mean everything Needs to be as High Quality as Possible
I started skating when I was 10 I'm real Serious about it so we've got the most Powerful Director Axis and the Batteries
Larger Capacity Than Any other Road board you Can Buy a jason Puts his Heart and soul Into Design
I would love to be in A the Mode
Is like Custom build the first Obvious Thing about this is the Handle
Having written Lots of Boards and Carrying the One-Wheel all Around this is Probably the Best Feature, well how about you
Also have like the Kickstand in the back Which, Is I'm going to Shopping that Daughter or Adults Instead I
Woke Up
Well you me that Easy?
Ready to Read Corner on the Street and You got a turn like Most boards you've got to go like this yeah
so Now if We look at the underside of this Thing
Also it's not heavy it's the x way it's Just Regular trucks you Can find on Any Electric skateboard but These Have Engineered Something very
Specific These Are Just normal Truck These are our Decision Machines A big part of Pop Motors is releasing the Heat Because everything's
Inside You They're Designed to dissipate the heat from the Motor yes so you can See the heatsink on the back of the Motor here
and
That's Connected to There so when the Motors Hollett you'll Feel this Is just As hot I'Ve got a Digital readout for how
Much range now You've got a beginner Mode on the Top and then our spec Mode on the Bottom you can See the width Difference
Here Yeah he Does Allow Us to put A lot more Talking to these Motors
These are the Final Wheels This is the Pre-Production out Wheels the Production Wheels?
Use a high rebound urethane They're Going to be A Lot Stronger Than These ones This Is an Injection molded Case
Which Houses The Battery at
432 What our Battery As long as to fuck Boxes to Pop Boxes These are the open Source Speed
Controllers and Then You've Got a Bluetooth Module
You've got a receiver
And then you've got a Switching Box and then you've got the bMS it's all modular so if you want to change this Outfit on?
And need that you can do Whatever you want you could Probably get to back in to Make a Four-Wheel drive Board
Sounds Like Insanity Yeah and Decided To perspective This Battery Is
Over Four Times Larger Than the Standard Boosted Battery Best way to put it in Perspective you sold a drag Race Video yeah
Old Boards, Were 100% at the end of That Test
Booster Bull was Bad and This Had 70%
Okay, you know, what I can't stand Anymore We Gotta go try? This Thing here We go?
I want to ride it I want to try it I'm Gonna Give a team Beginning my foot I
Mean Looking Buy More Red walls not that they don't have Flavored Burning well
It's also at the end of the day I try not to drink Any Caffeine After a Certain Time that
He just went for it
you know it's death A
Happy man in Slow-Mo a happy heart is good this is good
Let's Move out!
We see you guys I got in Them?
Who-Who's Make The First Red Bull you want a tip
No I'm okay to be Honest I don't quite know Exactly what's going on with Red Bull Those are a prop
These are Ours To Drink to Keep us awake and We Just are now going to Chemically Keep you
Awake to Make you Make even More Videos for all your enjoyment, oh?
No what the only hit This red Balls Because we've got to Hook up Through some of its Studio71 who has a Contact
With The People of Red bull and Since, we're Shooting the Battlegrounds Video we Figured a good way to get A
Bunch of Free Red Bull Because you drink Energy Drinks in Progress so
Have fun, stay up all night
Ooh!
Wooh!
Got some Brakes on it so i'm going to floor it I'm still in beginner mode, but I'm going to Floor it
This is beginner mode?!, oh my god because A lot of People, don't think of Motors can get off from Stansel very Quickly so
Watch
Three
Two one
God
oh my God okay, I've Heard A lot of Boards in my time This thing is Easily the fastest I
Got a Handle so i Can Mario Cart it I think I'm Ready for full Speed Mode, okay
I'm going to brace Myself for Sprinting I hope I don't die
Three Two one Go
Oh, Had to let off dang, dang, oh!
What a joy, oh, okay? It's too fast
Hrrrrr!!
Grrrr!!
I'm not even Hitting top speed and I'm Freaking out
*Weird climax noises*
That was incredible my god how fast does this go?
On 100% charge you'll get Fifty Four Fifty four Point Two Kilometers an Hour but Normally Forty nine Point Two Kilometers an Hour
Although Thirty Miles an Hour Top Speed that was Freaky that's going to Take some getting used to yeah
Woah, man I want to I want to know how you do that ha ha
It's Really important as an Electric skateboarder to be able to do that because
If for Any Reason your Electronics Failed you're going Down a hill there, was A red light the Call Came out that's your?
Safety so the only way I know how to stop Just drop my foot and slide it
Cost 30 K 30 Miles an Hour it's not Really possible, so you
Need to get real lows you got your Left Hand Depending if You're Goofy or Regular
you Can hold on to the board in This case you Can hold on to the Handle
Then You want to start Dropping your weight over
Over to the your Shoulder so
Pretty Much Just Trying all over
Till you're at a point Where you feel like this and then you just push the Urethane as hard as you Can you don't have
To Touch the Ground and on About yeah I got my Safety
Yeah I should Really learn that do you guys Going to be Showing This off on the 13th of August in
Portland Oregon Yeah my Hometown I'm Jealous so if Anyone wants to go check it out
We're also running a competition at every Event so if you want to win a rap the two
We're Going to do is you're going to Take a photo and Instagram With the Hashtag in Ocean Raptor I
I totally entered
you entered, I saw your... yep that was beautiful
Going like 75% Speed you're Saying you can go like 25 Miles
On a charge yep
What this, oh?
Finally done?
All done
Where did you Purposely wear a red shirt right now?
that was an accident yeah, so what did you do for the black lines? Just a paintbrush
But yeah, it Looks so smooth he Can't even Tell Is Made in eight Different Pieces
it's my very First one Ever so
Not too Bad for being my very First one The ton of Layers of red Spray Paint
Primer. In fact you can just go "Boop"
Really Nice It'll Hold, Itself just fine, so you bring it to the the PUBG Video right right?
no I'm not
Have to pee so Bad
Desperate Times Call for desperate Measures
Looks Like you're Going to have to subscribe to see what happens to Wren